What happens when 800 of the world’s most elite footballers
and their managers live together under one roof?
Players stop being polite
and start getting Real.
This is
The Champions
Man U?
More like Man Me
I don’t dress to impress
I dress to gegenpress
Can you tell us some more about yourself Kevin?
De Bruyne
Remember that amazing goal I scored to win the Puskas?
Neither do I
He’s coming! He’s coming!
You guys, you guys, get into position
I’m the most decorated. Respect!
Our great maestro arrives!
How are you?
Terrible
I could use a massage. My center back is killing me.
Hello, Red Devils
I apologize for being late
I lost the dressing room
I mean, I lost my way to the dressing room
It’s the media. The media want to say things are bad here.
They say my players are sad
They are wrong
And so to prove this I am forcing all the players to come to my party tonight
I’ve gathered you all here to remind you
that just because you are not good
doesn't mean we can't have a good time
Now enjoy your mandatory meal
What’s the matter, Luke?
Not enough cholesterol in this for you?
What is this?
This looks like crap
Excusez-moi
could I have a bigger roll?
I don't get Harry Maguire
you don't get more food
All right, let’s party!
Alexis, play...
Coach, I don’t really want to do this
Never list additional skills on your CV
Hello
Oh hey, David Moyes is here!
Goodbye
Aw, and he’s gone
Oh man, this is more boring than hearing Harry Kane
tell us about how much he misses his wife
OK, who wants to play a game?
You guys want to play a game?
So the object of this game is uh
you try to score once
and then after that you sit back and wait for time to run out
It’s the best way to waste 90 minutes!
Oh...a special ONE.
That means I get to throw a player under the bus
Let’s see…
Ah, so many choices! Oh, God....
How about...
I don’t want to play this anymore
Oh you will play where I say you play
Paul
Paul, I am kidding.
I only say this because you are my favorite
This game is not fun
Games are not supposed to be fun
They’re supposed to be hard and tedious
What is this?
What is this garbage?!
Paul!
Ooh, you traitor!
Can we go, coach?
Yeah, no problem
You’re loaned to Millwall
Hey, what are you doing here?
Someone told me that this party needed new energy
You were not invited
Go away